bitkha maybe the most important social
experiment going on right now and
because it is at the social level it's
an experiment technologically it's not
an experiment it is robust and it works
but because at the social level it's an
experiment there's still a chance that
it fails and therefore it's risky and
nobody should invest in Bitcoin an
amount of money that they cannot afford
to lose because of that risk but there's
also chance that it works out well and
if it works out well it may be the first
thing in 5,000 years that finally
replaces the gold standard which has
been the standard for quite a very long
time
and it becomes a new meta currency that
sits atop all currencies I don't think
Bitcoin should or would ever replace any
national currencies I think that
salaries need to be paid in local
currencies and countries need to have
their monetary policies and you need
lenders of last resort and the system
that we have in place and probably need
to stay at that level but people need to
have options and I think that bitcoin
will become probably the currency of the
internet or of the digital world but
also in in that sense a new currency
that sits at up all currencies and for
certain transactions that you do either
because there on the internet or because
they're international it makes more
sense to do them in Bitcoin
than in any other currency eventually
gold is decentralized nobody decides how
much colder is it's centralized there's
not one company or one country or one
person deciding how much colder is
there's also not one company one country
one person deciding what's the price of
gold it's decided in the market and also
there's not one person one country or
one company deciding what you can
exchange gold for it's totally
decentralized and it's also sort of
anonymous if I pay you with something
for something with gold there's no trace
of that if I pay you for something with
cash it's absolutely anonymous so I
think that we need to regulate Bitcoin
to have basic consumer protections to
prevent criminal activity on it
to prevent money laundry but I think
doing so is not hard and I think doing
so it's doable with the regulations that
we already have in place to account for
cash cash is very anonymous and we have
regulations in place to manage the
anonymity of cash and each country has
regulations to address people having
foreign currency so between the
regulations that exist for cash gold and
foreign currency you have all of the
regulatory infrastructure you need to
deal with Bitcoin but you do not need to
what we're seeing right now is because a
lot of the regulators are still getting
their arms around Bitcoin the first
reaction is it's a scare reaction that
tends to over-regulating which that
wouldn't wouldn't be good for the
regulators wouldn't be good for the
industry but I think we will get there
and it's not so complicated